I have to know scale of 1 to 10 how much
romance is gonna be in store for season
7 of 1 calls the heart 11:11
you're breaking the meter that's how
much romance truly a wedding I mean so
many suitors for Elizabeth yes
we're overflowing with romance when
calls the heart season 7 is coming to
Hallmark Channel in early 2020 but to
hold you over ét got an exclusive
preview of what's to come straight from
the cast on the vancouver sent lucas got
the dance i I have to know where is
Elizabeth hard at I like to think that
throughout season six Elizabeth was
really moving on with her life she was
she was making peace with having lost
Jack really becoming a single mother and
standing on her own two feet and by the
end of season 6 we see that she is
starting to become willing to open her
heart to love again and in season 7 we
we get to see a bit more of that as far
as how she feels about these two men I
think maybe she's a bit surprised that
she's got feelings for anyone let alone
two men it's hard to ignore when there's
two wonderful gentlemen who really have
just so much affection for Elizabeth
that's the thing right they're pretty
great guys they're both single
they're both look they're both handsome
yes point blank
I mean generous they're sensitive
they're good listeners they're good with
her kid I mean I have to think that Jack
would approve
so he'd want her to be happy he'd want
her to be happy and we are moving in
that direction I think the big thing
that we see this year with the two
suitors is that one of the suitors
pushes her to be better and one of the
suitors needs her to help him be better
Lucas is able to push Elizabeth in a way
that no one else does and challenge her
when she needs to be challenged in order
to help her grow as a person the thing
he has the most going for him is this
ability to do that Nathan is bad at
talking to girls I need to know how is
Nathan upping his game
and his chances in C's
got a haircut I don't like that's I
don't know Nathan needs to like read a
book on how to talk to women I think
Nathan looked at that last scene in
season six as I guess she's just not
interested yeah so I think outside
circumstances start kind of coming into
their lives and bringing them a bit
closer together
Lucas is more outgoing unafraid of
approaching Elizabeth
whereas Nathan is more more reserved and
he still continues to be reserved this
season but you can tell that he's
pushing more than I was a lot of the
Hardys they seem to think that Elizabeth
might not necessarily end up with Nathan
because he's a Mountie and then of
course in the back of her mind she might
fear that I could lose him the same way
I lost Jack what's your take on that
there's something so rich and
complicated about Elizabeth's
relationship with Nathan because he's a
Mountie I mean you can't really get
around that and obviously she's got
history with that profession there's a
lot of fear about that but I'm not gonna
sit here and say to you know that
definitely won't happen cuz it's
definitely enough I mean yeah there's a
great option I think Lucas he's
definitely attracted to Elizabeth and he
has the confidence to pursue her where I
think Nathan is attracted to her but you
know he also there's some history with
the Mounties clearly you know I think we
might even find out a little bit more if
Nathan and Jack might have known each
other so nathan has a bit more reserved
- maybe not aggressively priced
aggressively pursue something you know
that he kind of feels closely - oh you
know what that lost like that
no it's a tough call it's really a tough
[Music]
the addition of baby jack has been so
heart melting so I have to know what
sweet motherhood moments are in store
for Elizabeth and maybe not even sweet
maybe there's gonna be some challenges
well there are certainly challenges for
me as an actor oh of course
just wrangling the babies and you know
we have some little tricks to keep them
happy but there are some beautiful
tender moments of motherhood and I'm
honored to get to tell those stories but
you know first words first steps you
know just sweet little cuddly moments
where they're they like to hold on to me
and play with the buttons on my shirt it
just makes me melt
they're so cute will you be my wife
[Music]
I couldn't help it yeah you really
breathe Matt yes can you get a close-up
on that sure you got proposed to yes
season six finale of one calls the heart
so now we have to believe that there's
probably gonna be a wedding in season
seven is that true absolutely we have to
give a wedding Hope Valley loves a
wedding I know they do the best they
have the best wedding come on this is
hard you know it's wedding season baby
tradition with wedding mm-hmm you
typically don't see the bride until she
walks down the aisle
yes do you think on the day that you
shoot that moment you and Aaron are
gonna stay separate we've talked about
that I think I would like it to be
separate really like to be separated
yeah and have that you know genuine
moment of us seeing each other and we
walking down the aisle to him yeah do
you think he will be tearful oh
definitely
like hard to get through those
definitely I don't want to see you I
don't know I would really like if we
could I mean it's hard on set but if we
could keep me completely separated from
her until that moment I see her walking
up that would be so cool and get like
kind of like emotional already like I
mean what do you think your reactions
gonna be
I think it's gonna be an accumulation of
the last like five years together all
the beautiful moments we've shared our
first kiss our first date our first
picnic all these things and it's just
gonna come together right there
team infirmary after so many seasons of
waiting we finally saw the spark really
ignite between Carson and faith so where
does that pick up in season seven the
wonderful thing about season seven is
this push-pull dynamic that was
established in season six it's more
affirmative now we kind of I think will
see these characters making bolder
choices and committing to each other in
a way that we kind of haven't seen
before the relationship with faith has
progressed in that amount of time - like
with Andrea Brooks and my character
where they are in love and it's growing
in there's a lot happening with them
what kind of challenges is the couple
gonna face this season well when it
comes to faith I think she really starts
examining her career she's given up so
much in her life to put her career first
and at this point she's thinking maybe I
can do more than just be a nurse so
maybe medical school would be an option
we have this growing love Carson really
wants what's best for her and she took
all these extra courses in med school
and I find this out and I find out her
dream was to be a doctor so Carson has
to unselfishly put her career and her
dreams ahead of keeping her here for
like himself and for love and for mares
and for babies and family and go wait a
minute what's really gonna make her
happy this was her dream is to become a
doctor if you will get a lot of tender
loving Carson baby this TLC enough this
may not be our children but here in Hope
Valley or a part of everyone's family
because of you I have to talk to you
about rosemary and Lee's really touching
journey to get to Parenthood where are
they at with that when season seven
starts I think you see going into this
season that that ache is still there I
mean they both still do really want to
be parents and they don't know what the
grand plan is for them yet they're
figuring it out they're figuring it out
and they're waiting to kind of see that
unfold for them and figure that out so
that's where we see the two of them
Kevin is he is my partner in crime he's
my greatest creative companion I've ever
had and so it we just really support
each other we support each other in the
comedy and we support each other into
the drama I don't pay child there's no
matter how much I may want my child the
only thing in the whole world
I really need is you the two of us were
able to talk about that and say okay how
how far do we want to go with the the
emotion like and what works and what
doesn't work and so there was a lot of
conversations between the two of us of
how we wanted that to play we wanted the
release like the cathartic release but
we didn't want it to end in total
devastation we wanted it to end in this
loving connection of the two of them
it's a delicate position to be in like
you don't want to do the stereotypical
thing you don't want to rush it
I think it's problem that a lot of
people have so I hope that the way it
finally resolves itself this season is
good for everybody they totally deserve
it I think something will happen there
are several theories all of them are
interesting I hope one of them actually
happens in this season Lee and rosemary
are committed they want to become
parents what steps are they taking in
season seven to go about that route
right now I think the two of them are
committed to trying to find joy in their
life even if that doesn't mean children
at this particular moment and I think
they are doing that to relieve the
pressure I think so often it can be
a singular focus and everything you do
and everything you talk about revolves
around selves exactly and so I think
they're trying to not have that get back
to the heart of what like their joy
their joy as a couple and their joy is
baby Jack's guardian exactly there have
been this season there's been a lot of
scenes with the two of them and baby
Jack and it's really cute to see Lee and
rosemary like interacting with baby Jack
and of course it's just like full
immersion I almost feel like in those
scenes that rather than just like the
neighbors that live next door it's
almost like they're the grandparents you
know what grandparents are with
grandkids with their life literally like
their world stops when their grandkids
are in the it's like that with Lee and
Rose news like if baby jack is around
like nothing else matters if everything
is about him if you had your way about
it why would you want to see them
explore the adoption absolutely there's
an orphanage in Brookfield for sure and
I think that's that's primarily where
we're leaning I think adoption makes the
most sense
I think it's an interest that the way
was set up last year I think it really
kind of lend itself well to that I also
think that it doesn't close the door
entirely for her conceiving I think it
could be any wish that anything gonna
happen
[Music]